hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf and
this is family tussle the father-son
competition show where the loser has to
do an embarrassing punishment let's go
the competition today is boxing this
competition is for every old dude out
there
it's us against them he thinks his
cardio is better than mine right now
just because he works out which I think
is very cute I was a black belt in
Taekwondo by the age of nine and uh
almost a black belt in Krav Maga about
age of 13. I've been punched before
that's how quick I'm gonna be but you
see this right here I just threw five
punches six punches seven punches I'm
not kidding I think I just pulled a
muscle in my net
oh my God is that what my breath smells
like
like a camel's [ __ ] watch out these
hands are coming
you see that
[Music]
you'll see the SE
they're coming for it
that's all I got to say
all right buddy here we are at the
boxing gym I'm here with Brendan and kez
and Freddie they are the trainers I
figure since he's gonna get his ass
kicked he should be able to pick who he
wants to train him so you pick okay
whatever you want to say I mean on that
I'm taking Bishop over there
all right I was pick blasting great
school too
I'll keep my eyes on all these
[Music]
Pro judge just my entrance in the ring
right there one through ten
I don't want to
this is what boxers don't they have
bracelets yeah they all wear braces
have you ever seen a wrist quite this
masculine dainty
it's a stupid ass bracelet that's how
much turquoise are you wearing right now
I'm a turtle Freddy
I'm not gonna tell you anything you know
your dad's old yeah so we're going to
the body but for real you don't have to
move your head he's in his 20s you're 57
years old not 57 stop saying that hold
on do you remember what happened last
time he almost threw up a minute into
the end of the round like out and how
long ago was that
you were two years old he was two years
old his dad fought him and now look at
you yeah one punch broken red we're good
I'm in yep
that's good if I want to do exercises to
strengthen my liver right now yeah
they're not you're fighting in five
minutes Josh that's way better than
giving yourself credit for man
[Music]
let's go I'm ready
already
in this corner he's ready to slam first
from Amherst
smoking the best grass in West Mass
panel show prize fighter from Chelsea
Lately to my son hates me the arthritic
Semitic just whoa
in this corner
Jay
come on now
remember that
you're in the will okay yeah also
remember
[Music]
[Music]
okay yeah
[Music]
come on
[Music]
all right time
no you're okay you're okay you're okay
this whole fight is just me yelling keep
your hands up I do love Josh and he's
older but the the check hooked to the
right hand it's gonna stop this fight
all right how much time do we have ref
I love that you have two minute breaks
in between your one minute round he was
gassed after 30 seconds yeah 62. he is
62 years old
foreign
[Music]
all right
how come I thought he was gonna be way
more tired than me no I told you before
this fight started the second round was
gonna be the hardest one for you for you
you were right
yep but the the straight right to the
bodies they just gotta commit to it I I
kept telling Jake I'm like dude ripped
through the body let's get out of here
say it again
go up top knock your dad out let's go
over and get some food man he's like
dude it's my dad relax the blood comes
to the muscle and it fatigues
in the 80s you get massages now you just
gut it out of curiosity where do you
think
the blood in my body is right now in
your feet
[Music]
all day
[Music]
yeah good one come on
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what the winner looks like right
there how come I thought I was gonna be
and so much better shape than you
that was for sure that was my whole
strategy
and we knew that
[Music]
30-29 Jakey wolf is my is my fault it's
that third round's so close he landed
early on one guy was a little bit busier
landed a few more combos landed a more
devastating punch and it's mine hearing
you're right
we are we all thought you'd be down in
one so really
how did you feel about the skills that
you saw on display oh man there were
skills in there
you were in I'm gonna tell you right now
I'm super proud of you you rocked it bro
yeah thank you I appreciate it and uh
you definitely you landed more punches
than last time so that's definitely a
win for you and your book I'll give you
that I love you man what's up okay right
here hit me
oh yeah now I just have to wait and see
another punishment but my punishment is
oh yeah it's gonna be uh
now so we're here at the T-man Tattoo
Studio in Studio City
um and Jacob has picked a tattoo for
this punishment I think I'm not gonna
show you until it's done so I'm a
control dude and I figured I'd be able
to okay tattoo why don't you hop in a
nutshay
all right oh me too dude I've Googled
butthole tattoos before I've done them
oh it looks pretty
okay somebody can tell me what that says
all right are you ready yeah I guess
[Music]
get the [ __ ] out of here
does that say Jake 's my biological dad
[Music]
the next time I take my shirt off around
your mom did you tell her oh no I'm just
gonna let you deal with it when you get
home you think I was gonna tell Mom
about this she would have said no she
would have maybe change it
[Music]